let me call this guy here david i'm
calling you here from cuba let's see
what david has to say on what it is to
have lived in cuba for 15 years david if
you're listening i'm calling you
and the next person i'm calling right
after this is rolando
gonzalez david can you hear us
i called him do you want me to put him
on speaker or what do you want me to do
he's on david can you hear me yes i can
hear you
okay david so tell us tell us your
background what you do what your
experience has been with cuba how many
years you lived there
give us a little bit about your
background 30 seconds hey patrick first
of all thank you thank you for having me
i came to this country when i was 18
years old that was uh
six years ago i came by myself no family
only couple friends in here
i've been listening to you for a long
time i start my business
uh listening to you so i love this
country and one of the reasons i love
this country is uh because you have at
least two sides
and that's what people don't understand
about cuba uh on the news right now
they're saying that we are protesting
against uh kobe then against food
nothing like that in response to island
what what are they saying about that
is because the news over here they don't
want to discuss against the socialists
and the only reason that we are
protesting in q1 is because the
communist regime
nothing else we have been for 62 years
we have no food
we have no liberty nothing so right now
we're
david tell me are you in communication
with your family in cuba right now
yeah so what they did yesterday after
the first day of everything goes to the
street they shut down the internet
so right now they got our entire country
on shot down so the only way that we can
uh spoke with them is paying uh paying
money over here i'm making them
pay money over there but they cannot
share anything that is happening right
now
so when my mom twenties uh 20 minutes
ago much better they got like on the
they got on like on the on the smaller
towns they got on the on the center of
the town yeah got the president
on the speaker shouting like like
everything is okay this is uh
follow the united states because embargo
there is no embargo
because they still have yes they are
millionaires and the people from cuba
are hungry
and they are ripping the people from
united states here because we have to
send anything
to to help or mom somehow or family in
cuba
like for example patrick my brother is a
doctor he
he used to make 40 dollars in cuba a
month that's how much highest
how much money for 40 a month wait let
me get this straight your brother's a
doctor he made
forty dollars a month is the highest
salary in cuba as a doctor
and used to put that in perspective
right now a tylenol
like ten pillars thailand or for
headaches is a hundred dollars in cuba
wow it's a hundred dollars so think alan
think about that
when when you guys talk about social
media companies and
the left wing and i'm saying this i
really like you and it's really good to
have democrat friends
because i have democrat friends and all
that's good that you guys are good
because we we need two sides
you know sometimes we are too over
yourself and you it's good to have two
sides
but that's that the side that is only
this country the democrats the main guys
they're all corrupt because they they
don't even want to talk about cuba
right now because a lot of people bought
it for biting because the same reason
that you say because you don't like
trump
and we don't like trump either but we
know that this was going to happen if we
have trump right now in business even
though that we don't like it
he was gonna put a better position again
in cuba
and the reason that biter is not taking
that position is because they are trying
to protect him that
like the socialist agenda that they get
so
uh my brother my brother was a doctor he
made 40 dollars in cuba so he had to go
uh work to fight seven uh days a week
and after he finished saving lives
with the motorcycle that he by making a
bakery in our home so he
he had to go to the doctor uh save life
and then come back i'm
spending four or five hours of making
like small bakeries
uh to sell with helping my mom helping
everybody help them that's
that's the only way that you can survive
in cuba let me let me ask you a question
david
when trump announced the sanctions nine
months ago that he put on cuba where no
american person can stay on a
a property in cuba i believe that's a
cuban owned property
when he put those sanctions to hurt the
economy of cuba to
hopefully have a revolution where the
people would go up against the
government
how did the people in cuba feel about
trump's sanctions he posed against cuba
patrick 95 percent of cuba know that
that is good
because they even without that sanctions
they still having bad thrones
for 62 years there's nothing new for 62
years
we have to send money from here to the
western union let's say
so what they do is they take your
dollars the dollar that i make
they keep it and then they give you some
monopoly uh dollars to the to the people
so right now instead of making those if
i send a hundred dollars on cuba right
now
they only give it like 80. on paper that
don't work for nothing
so everybody in q1 don't let like the
news from here
letting you otherwise everybody in q1
knows that we have to be harder without
with the deterioration
because even though these sanctions
don't affect enough in the country
they only affect the people on uh on
power
they got they got uh they got uh they
got jazz on ibiza right now
castro's sons castro's daughter
everybody is flying out
raul castro they he took a plane
yesterday to venezuela
so i've been talking i've been texting
to your program like for
four months uh four uh four weeks ago
patrick because i know that you do a lot
of interviews for everybody i've been
following for a lot of years
and i hope in the future you can do
something about this the main reason
that we got this socialist influence on
the united states right now
is cuba cuy is behind venezuela military
on cuba
is ruining venezuela well first of all
david thank you so much for uh
being a giving us your perspective of
where you're at
uh and appreciate you listening to this
completely different perspective on what
you said on what's going on with cuba
uh once again thank you for your time
david appreciate you and padre
hello yeah i'm listening go ahead uh
yeah just wanna
shout out to my people in san nicolas
party they they came out to the tree
yesterday but there are smaller towns
people in havana commonwealth big cities
are still out
and for my people here in the united
states i want to let you know this is
what happened
when you let people from the government
take your guns this is what happened
with the government
is too big all these stimulus shake
that's what they do they give you free
money now
and then when they take it apart from
you then you're 15 years from now you
have nothing
so you cannot defend yourself and
patrick for the people that are saying
that
this is a civil war this is not civil
war because we don't have guns they are
killing my people in the town
my people have nothing no not even uh
not even alcohol battles with fire
they got nothing and they they kill a
kid yesterday 13 years old the police
get a kid
and uh they shoot somebody on the face
right next to my town
so they are killing my people don't let
the news saying otherwise
this is like hong kong like everybody
say they are trying to say something
different now
my people is on the street we don't have
guns we are trying to take the gun from
the police
but we can't we don't have guns they got
tanks they got everybody
everybody on the united states right now
is asking for intervention
military in cuba we don't care what
happened next we just don't want the
dictatorship there
for all that i care
and make you on the next puerto rico
even if you want to stay even these ill
and most want to send
tell the factory and make everybody
uncool and work work for the meaningful
salary
they can do that we cubans are a part of
that we don't we don't care about the
the the the companies the social
elements that's why everybody in cuba is
voting for trump
because something something different
what's your every every every people
here ask oh what cuban people vote for
trump because this situation
every immigrant that is right here in
this country right now we have been
running from our left government
running here from the left oh my gosh
it's tough to debate that now this is
firsthand david once again appreciate
you man thank you so much have a good
one
appreciate it any time what a
perspective what a perspective don't you
think we really have to follow what our
reaction as a country
is in cuba other than saying we're
monitoring it i mean don't we have to
step in and help these people at some
point
not militarily though the perspective
that the media gives you
they tell you the reason why this is
happening
is because of coronavirus jen what's up
what's her name
she said it's because we need to send
them more vaccine shots that's why
they're protesting they're not
protesting backs anybody
this is not a vaccine protest this is
not a covet protest this is they're sick
and tired of
a doctor making 40 bucks a month and
tylenol costs a hundred dollars for 10
pills
you kidding me and you heard what he
said about the gun thing where police
killed a 13 year old yesterday in the
city and the town right next to the town
he was uh
uh living it completely different
perspective i'm going to call the next
person here
rolando gonzalez is a mechanical
engineer from cuba
moved at 26 years old and has lived here
for lived in florida for the last 14
years so 40 years old 26 years in cuba
let's see what perspective he's got for
us two things the fact that they shut
off the internet
i mean how horrific is that for
everybody they can't even communicate
and they took their guns so forget about
having a coup how do you communicate
i haven't had guns rolando how are you
hi davey how you doing i'm doing fine
i'm
appreciated you take this time any time
so give us perspective what do you think
about what's going on and if you're
communicating with your family in cuba
what do they tell you that telling you
that's happening over there that the
media is not telling us
first than anything i want to say thank
you to you guys
tom adams padre kai everyone's there
for you know help me to tell the war
what is happening in cuba
shout out to david he he explained a lot
i think right now we are on big problems
i
i've been in communication with my
family yesterday night
they was able to use vpn to get access
to
whatsapp and they don't know i'm from a
small town they don't know
anything about what's happening around
there i begin to send them pictures to
them
and i helping them to put the other cell
phones that they got to vpn
also yeah so they can be able to see
that the big problem is we don't have
internet they don't have communication
in between
they chop down the light they're playing
something now they call point kasich
which is like taking out the
communication take the towns
they mobilize regular people to fight on
different towns let's say if you are
from
miami they take you from miami to five
to four lord of the people
and then they bring people from fort
lauderdale to find miami
why are they doing it what's the reason
for doing that well
they say they say in cuba you have to go
to military service
it's obligatory right so they prepare
you for that
right so what they doing is they say oh
these people are from you know
is a people that got influenced from the
united states so let's gonna put it
you know let's gonna bring us to what we
need or social
you know and there is communication
between both way the problem is
you are from a small town you don't know
anything what is happening
and then town next to you and they take
you there when they put you there you
don't know what you're fighting for
you know you were training to fight you
know an enemy from outside of the
country not
to your own people that's what they're
doing
um i sent kai i sent kai on the text
a picture how they are like two two
policemen
with a young kid that certain year old
that they
kill they got i sent you another video
there
also um you can put it after and second
you can see how like six eight people
beating
to each other it's crazy what the police
is doing is
totally run let me ask you a question
who's creating this division
is their division being created the
government is the government so how are
they
how are they pinning people against each
other what's their method of pinning
people against each other
okay so they go to your home says okay
we got an intervention
and we need your be a part of this one
because you're part of the reserve
right yep they take you they put you in
another town yeah you don't have any
news
you don't know anything like the same
you was talking about they didn't got it
that
that news there that was totally run
it's the same with cnn
yet to deny what's what say what is this
they're they're getting the information
so wrong they don't get the right
information
everything that david said before was
right he was totally right
they're manipulating the informations
going in and out and
here the left is doing the same let me
let me ask you this other question when
you are somebody that lived in cuba for
26 years you've been here for
four uh 14 years you're 40 years old i'm
assuming you got why
you got a family right you're a family
man yourself yes sir okay yes
how do you see what's happened in
america do you see any similar trends
with what's happening here
with what happened in cuba do you see
any similar trends
oh definitely definitely i would say
something pretty
shout out to ben shapiro yet today he
says something pretty good
let's take the people who doesn't love
america send them to cuba
and let's bring the people who love who
love freedom
bring them here yeah to do that that's
going to be
absolutely impossible because aoc will
have a very hard time selling her 20
sweaters for 60 in cuba because even a
doctor couldn't afford to buy her
sweater in cuba
anyways thank you so much hold on one
question for you yeah go for it
sure what's your name again buddy
rolando rolando
yes sir other than the covid
right obviously that's change the world
what's different
now between five years ago 10 years ago
20 years ago
socialism communism castro they've been
there what's different now
other than covet okay first
you back like let's say a year ago you
got two
two currencies there you can buy a list
with that two currencies
now you get paid on cuban money but you
cannot buy on cuba money you have to buy
with dollars
then they say no we don't want dollars
we want
euros now so basically they're paying
you and cuban money but you cannot go
and buy let's say a beer or just
like cigarettes so you're saying what
you're saying the one thing that has
changed is
the currency that's accepted well
again this is just because they want the
people from the outside
pay their their things you know let's
say if i send now money to my family
yeah
they cannot let's say i put it here a
hundred dollar a hundred and thirty
dollars
my family get a hundred dollars but they
don't get a hundred dollars they get it
in cuba
david said by the way they can't they
cannot go to the
they cannot go to their stores and buy
food
so if you wire money from here if you
send money from your western union to
your family in
cuba no no no black market blood market
you don't do westwood martin that's what
he's saying it's you don't do well you
don't do
they go out of the country they go out
of the country
so it's basically if you go to the
government you put like 130 here you
probably get like 80 there
but always they don't have money
who is covering the story on media like
if you were to say a
a certain podcast a certain news station
a certain newspaper that's covering the
accurate stories of what's going on in
cuba
who would you say okay okay um
it's a it's a radio guy from miami
that make an interview to josuel which
is a musician from
from cuba who lives in miami they're
covering the the history pretty good
there what's his name
is from the group origins yeah can you
write that down
let's write that down y-o-u-t-e-l
y-o-u-t-e-l we're trying to get a hold
up
[Music]
these people are these people are
calling the history pretty good
um i will i would suggest to go to
facebook
and look for people who are posting
videos you know
and all the news here and saying oh this
protest
was just on sunday it wasn't just a
sunday was
sunday monday and still doing today
again
what's that but we are getting the
videos pretty late ricky always called
trash about jorge ramos
what are your thoughts on jorge ramos i
i don't like it
i don't see any honestly i don't see any
lighting
um media at all hmm you don't see any
what you don't see anywhere oh you mean
for univision
yeah like latinos latinos latinos media
no
no univision no let me ask you a
question why are so many latinos in
america
not supportive of what you stand for why
are so many latinos and media who
escaped
socialism who escaped the the
experiences they had
why are they not supporting you know
and i'm not talking about everybody
there's a lot of people that are there's
a lot of people in media that'll say
it's not fair what's going on and by the
way that that could be on the left and
the right you heard what
rubio said yesterday you heard what the
mayor of miami suarez said yesterday
he was out there protesting he was out
there representing the people on
monday and now this is not negotiable
yeah this is not negotiable but
why are so many people in media just
kind of like oh you know it's
it's it's kovit it's vaccine because
because
first thing is patrick language is a
huge
barrier and a lot of people is coming
from cuba
they don't have they don't speak english
even my english is very bad but i can
understand everything
people doesn't doesn't speak english so
the only way that they have to see
is whatever they see on media
i would say guys i love i know what
you're doing i follow you guys and i
think it's pretty good
the way that you're doing honestly i
open google every morning
read the news and my others might the
other way that i do is just go to your
podcast
well that's that's great to hear and we
appreciate the support rolando thank you
so much for giving us perspective on how
things are going right now in cuba
uh and uh we wish you and your family
not about the very best man appreciate
you thank you
thank you guys how interesting is that
you hear about
you know what's crazy somebody commented
and they said now has this become a
right wing podcast is what somebody said
no what at all
what part of what we just did do we do
we know who rolando is i've i don't know
wrong i've never met this guy
do i know who david is i've never met
david we're getting perspective
of what they're saying but because the
story and the narrative they're saying
doesn't
match what telemundo what univision and
what cnn and what msnbc
what some others are saying this is
automatically a right wing
versus a group of people that are
independent thinkers
yes you may be a little bit more center
left yes i may be a little bit more
center right yes you may be a little bit
whatever different
feelings that we have but automatically
look where identity politics goes you
automatically go that's what this person
is that's what that person so let me
just say something yeah
i'm born and raised in miami i've grown
up with cubans
all like born and raised in miami yeah i
grew up i
lived up until moving up to boca a mile
outside of little havana i
tons of cuban friends i know the mayor
very well i have
tons of cuban friends and this is
nothing new
meaning they've been they came here in
the late 70s early 80s obviously
you know people came here in the 1950s
after castro but people i know
have been here for a long time this is
nothing new in regards to
we've been we've known what socialism
and communism has done to cuba
and venezuela for years what i think is
happening now
why where the covet thing is is
one of the things that cuba gets
recognized for
is their socialized medicine and
socialized education
and that is clearly falling apart right
now covet has exacerbated the problems
that exist in communism now there's food
shortages
obviously they turned off the internet
social unrest
high food prices collapsing
infrastructure kai i actually went to
cuba i don't know if we want to pull
this up right now
but this is nothing new we've i've
miamians have been talking trash about
cuba
forever so if you enjoyed this little
short segment from the podcast that we
did here's another short segment to
watch or if you want to see the entire
podcast
click over here take care everybody bye